نحن نتحدث عن اعلى هيئه قضائيه في العالم
فان قراراتها نهائيه وغير قابله للاستناد
[موسيقى]
هناك رمزيه كبيره وابعاد سياسيه واقليميه
يعني على اتهاد اسرائيل وتجريمها باعظم
جريمه في تاريخ الانسانيه وهي الجينوسايد
الاباده الجماعيه بالذات لان اسرائيل
كدوله يهوديه هي نتاج لجريمه الاباده
الجماعيه الهولوكوست ببان الحكم النازي في
المانيا لذلك من المهم لها ان لا تتهم
وبالضرورة
الشرق الاوسط بالذات اليوم وجدت اسرائيل
نفسها امام ورطه عالميه بكل ما يتعلق
بالراي العام العالمي المذهول من المشاهد
الصعبه التي تبث من غزه من تقيل جماعي
لعشرات الالاف الفلسطينيين واباده غزه
وتدميرها حيث اصبحت الان غير قابله للسكن
وهذا كله يضرب شرعيه اسرائيل لذلك قرارها
بالمثول امام المحكمه نابع ايضا من اجل
طرح وفرض الروايه الاسرائيليه النتيف
لتبييض صورتها امام
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
العالم لا يتم بشكل عام تصريح علنا عن نيه
الدول بانها ستقوم بارتكاب جريمه الاباده
الجماعيه ولكن يمكن الاستدلال من الاعمال
العسكريه على ارض الواقع على نيه الاباده
بمعنى ان تصريحات القيادات الاسرائيليه
التي هي بمثابه اعتراف بنيه اسرائيل
بتدمير غزه وسكانها هي دليل اضافي اكسترا
يعني بمعنى انه من شانه تقويه الادله التي
تجرب اسرائيل بارتكاب جريمه الاباده
الجماعيه تمام ولكن عمليا هي ممكن تجريمها
حتى من دون هذه
التصريحات اسرائيل سوف تدعي امام محكمه
العدل الدوليه ثلاث مراكز او ثلاث محاور
لادعاءات اول ادعاء ادعاء الحق في الدفاع
عن نفس لكن هذا الادعاء لا يحق لدوله
محتله اتجاه المقاومين للاحتلال ثانيا
شيطنه حماس والتركيز على اعماله العدائيه
وصف تنظيم ارهابي وانه ليست حركه مقاومه
والى اخره ولكن هذا الامر من شان اسرائيل
ان يعطيها الشرعيه باستهداف مقاتلي حماس
الذين حسب ادعاءات اسرائيل طبعا يهتمون
بالمدنيين ويستعملونه كدروع بشريه طبعا
هذا يناقض الواقع في غزه ولكن ايضا يناقض
مبدا الت ناسب الذي يمنع استهداف المدنيين
لقتل العسكريين بمعنى الوضع في غزه الان
انه يتم ضرب الاحياء السكنيه المدنيه عسى
ان يكون هناك مقاتلي حماس هذا يدل انه
اصبح اليوم مقاتلي حماس هم الاضرار
الجانبيه وليس العكس ثالثا سوف تقوم
اسرائيل بتفنيد نيه الاباده وهو ركن اساسي
حقيقه في جريمه الاباده الجماعيه كيف سيتم
ذلك من خلال الادعاء ان تصريحات القيادات
الاسرائيليه هي تصريحات سياسيه وتندرج تحت
الحق في التعبير عن الراي ولكن هذه
التصريحات حسب قول اسرائيل هي غير
ملزمه سيدخل اسرائيل الى بوتقه او قائمه
او القائمه السوداء من الانظمه المشؤومه
والمرفوض في العالم هذا من شانه كمان مره
ضرب شرعيه اسرائيل كدوله طبيعيه في
المجتمع الدولي ويص صعب بالضروره من
اندماجها في المجتمع الدولي الحر والشرق
الاوسط بشكل خاص اسرائيل سوف تصبح عاله
على الدول المسانده لها وعلى الدول
المطبعه معها وهذا قد يؤدي الى تقويه
حركات المقاومه العسكريه ضدها وحركات
المقاومه الدوليه مثل البي دي اس وغيرها
من الحركات المقاطعه لاسرائيل وبالتالي
اضعاف مكانه اسرائيل سياسيا اقتصاديا
علميا واجتماعيا وكل مناحي العلاقات
الدوليه بالمقابل سيقوي هذا من مكانه
ومطالب ومطالب حركات التحرر الوطني
الفلسطيني الذي يطالبون بدعم وانشاء
والاعتراف بالدوله
الفلسطينيه الان المحكمه سوف تنظر بالتماس
جنوب افريقيا الذي يتهم تتهم به اسرائيل
بارتكاب جريمه الاباده جماعيه على مرحلتين
المرحله السريعه والمرحله البطيئه الان
يعني المرحله السريعه هي مرحله النظر في
طلب جنوب افريقيا باصدار اوامر مؤقته ضد
اسرائيل تمنع ارتكاب جريمه الاباده
الجماعيه بحق
فلسطينيه ومن بعدها النظر بالقضيه
الاساسيه وموضوعها هل بالفعل قامت اسرائيل
بارتكاب جريمه الاباده ام لا بعد اصدار
الاوامر المؤقته تبدا المداولات بالقضيه
الاساسيه تقوم اسرائيل وجنوب افريقيا
تقديم الادله والبينات تقديم الطعون
الكتابيه والى اخره بعدها ستقوم المحكمه
باصدار قرار نهائي وهذا القرار سوف يكون
باغلبيه القضاه بما يشمل القضاه التي تم
تعيينهم بشكل مؤقت لهذه القضيه بسمو قضاه
ادهوك اللي هم عمليا تم تعيينهم من قبل
جنوب افريقيا واسرائيل كدول متنازعه بها
امام المحكمه بمعنى ان القرار النهائي سوف
يكون باغلبيه على الاقل تسع قضاه من من
اصل
نحن نتحدث عن اعلى هيئه قضائيه في العالم
فان قراراتها نهائيه وغير قابله للاستئناف
اي ان القرارات المؤقته هي نهائيه بمعنى
ان على الدول المتنازعه الالتزام والان
والانصياع لها وكذلك الامر ايضا بخصوص
القرار النهائي وفي حل رفض الدوله تنفيذ
القرار بحقها يمكن احاله القرار الى مجلس
الامن الدولي لفرضه على الدوله المخله
طبعا مجلس الامن من شانه اتخاذ كافه
الاجراءات القانونيه لالزام الدوله بتنفيذ
القرار طبعا هناك صلاحيه لنقل القرار الى
الهيئه العامه للامم المتحده التي من
شانها اتخاذ قرارات عقابيه بحق الدوله
المخله وهذه الخطوات قد تشمل يعني طرد
الدوله المخله من الامم المتحده وهذا جزء
من صلاحيات الهيئه العامه في هذا
السياق